quelle personnalité publique vous
aimeriez voir entrer dans votre
gouvernement et pourquoi
alors j'ai pas mal d'idées j'aimerais
voir entrer le général pierre de
villiers à la défense teddy riner à la
jeunesse leila slimani à la francophonie
[Musique]
monsieur
erreur
avec parfois une chanson vaut mieux
qu'un long discours
et puis sud ouest 1 sud ouest qui est
partenaire sur cette délocalisation avec
nous nous parle de la corse comment
éteindre le feu qui vous voyez peut-être
autour de moi qui si ce sont les
prisonniers basques qui qui interpelle
quelques militants sont invités
évidemment autour de moi c'est c'est les
aléas du direct voilà et la démocratie
qui s'expriment
s'il faut y aller à bach dont vous à
dire bye bye à l'itie si vous allez
chanter en attend son championnat mais
en direct en étant direct et ya eu ce
qu'on va lui donne des ordres
[Rires]
quand votre père rentre un jour chez lui
et qui a effectivement mireille darc et
aussi dans le salon le président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben il rentre
il le voit et il lui dit monsieur je
vous demanderais je vous prierais de
sortir je ne reçois chez moi que les
gens que j'invite jusqu'à s'est levé il
a remis la mèche et les sorties et les
sorties pour moi le mental peut être un
formidable allié de la spiritualité
j'aimerais même plus loin ne pas
l'utiliser ça nous fait perdre tout
discernement ça nous rend nunuche ça
nous rend manipulable c'est ça
le mot talent est important commune se
faire une bouillabaisse nous ce sont dix
paquets oui
je pense pas pareil c'est pas la même
chose
ça fait longtemps vous aurez pas manger
de
temps parce que tu es pas
on vous a proposé clara morgane danse
avec les stars j'ai fait mais oui à la
fête
après on assume j'assume j'assume parce
que je ne regarde que france 2
voilà des émissions qui sont sur une
autre chaîne et qui ne nous intéresse
pas et c'était des gros salaires à tf1
et celle d'animateur dortoir bah oui oui
mais c'était dirigé nice touché des
boutons de manchette à
gérer mon projet n'est autre qu'un coin
jean pierre alaux vous et combien ça
coûte c'était entre 25000 et 30000 euros
le prime en tant qu'animateur le plus ce
sont cinq heures de présence au coeur du
trésor attend donc ça fait le charme
c'est enzo édition de son journal oui je
pense du salaire en tant qu'animateur et
donc comme un stack ont été touchés donc
c'est lé dos avait 120 mille euros par
mois on est dans le dans le confort plus
plus plus la thalasso
battus
ces lettres facilement et il alla vian
sera tout un baigneur parce que ça tant
parce que l'animal est premièrement si
au japon les animaux sont massés avec de
la bière la version française est nourri
avec des chips
[Musique]
je crois assez balèze j'adorais la
fraude de faux qu un jour qu'il va faire
un ce qu'on appelle noah ménages
c'est-à-dire animé dans une ville à un
événement et on lui dit c'est combien et
je crois qu'il réponde pas pour que mon
temps je peux me tromper mais il répond
à 20000 euros et le maire de la ville du
divin 1000 euros pour deux heures ils
n'ont pour vingt ans de carrière
pendant très très longtemps pensé qu'il
fallait s'occuper de soi pour accroître
sa confiance en soi et en fait toutes
les études qu'on a depuis quelques
années sur l'altruisme le fait de
proposer son aide aux autres montrent
que aider les autres ça nous fait du
bien émotionnellement et ça améliore
l'image qu'on a de soi c'est à dire que
ans en aidant les autres on se rapproche
d'une vérité profonde de l'être humain
humain est un animal social vous déjà
fait l'amour dans un ascenseur sans
ascenseur c'est quoi
faites vite il j'ai faim
lève toi et fais la table depuis qu'il a
2 femmes la vie d'alexis n'est plus tout
à fait la même bien sûr il est toujours
le chef de famille
enfin presque
un jour alors que je disputais l'une
l'autre sans chercher à comprendre
disque m'a roué de coups moment où
j'ouvre les yeux le premier mot que je
dis c'est merci merci pour cette journée
merci d'être en vie a pigé mon chéri ou
ma chérie à côté de mort ah bah merci de
d'être ensemble et de se faire une
journée de mercy mais oui mais c'est
jouable durant six mois dites moi si tu
peux aller plus loin est-ce que moi
quand je me cogne la la c'est pas moi le
coude avec une pente je remercie saura
peut être plus grave finalement en fait
je suis toujours tout est un bienfait
tout peut devenir un bien fait c'est
toujours plus grave finalement et ça
nous permet en tout cas non bah c'est
parce qu'on s'aime qu'on s'est marié
sinon on ne vivrait pas ensemble
mais nous l'avons mis en garde il n'a
pas intérêt à prendre une troisième
femme
et pourtant les deux épouses d'alexis
vont avoir une très mauvaise surprise
leur conjoint va de nouveau se marier il
va même épousé deux femmes
supplémentaires d'un coup pour lui à 10
ans déjà adulte césar mais un homme en
est un homme
savez-vous l'expriment comment sous
quelle forme vous fais ma manière
versailles et mireille il raconte une
anecdote un jour il j'avais ciseaux et
et il partait tournée m'a laissé seul
avec mireille c'est mimi qui raconte ça
à la télé un jour et en partant me dit
anthony nos maintenant c'est toi l'homme
de la maison
damman le divorce avec mes parents
n'étaient pas loin à peine il a claqué
la porte que je me retourne vers
mireille et je dis maintenant toi tu
t'en bas
dans cette société patriarcale
le partage des tâches est assez simple
les femmes préparent tous
les hommes s'occupent du reste
là
on va passer par une étape de tri qui
vais assez radical assez drastiques
pourquoi parce que le but est de
supprimer le superflu et me mettre que
l'essentiel en vous carton le superflu
c'est un peu tout ce que tu as ici même
toit le superflu c'est pourquoi avoir 5
slip alors que peut avoir que deux
triplés retourner